so yeah so you know in case you're just
tuning back in you know this is the
Simon quantum protocols workshop and our
next speaker will be Richard Clank from
Caltech and he's going to tell us about
getting around this exponential
complexity barrier tomography and you
know just a reminder you know feel free
to ask questions in the Q&A window I'll
monitor that and when the questions pop
up I'll relay that to Richard all right
Richard it's all yours
hi everyone first of all I want to thank
the organizers for making this workshop
happen given the circumstances I must
confess that I was looking forward to
this workshop for months now and I
actually adjusted try to adjust my
return to Europe in order to just
physically make it to the workshop but
now Colonna happened and I'm sitting in
Austria back in my home country in order
to give this talk and it's also actually
a special date because you introduced me
as a postdoc at Caltech but today is
literally my last day as a Caltech
worker and tomorrow I'm going to start a
new job at the department of computer
science at the honest capital University
in Linz Austria and I'm very excited to
talk to you about a very new and
exciting project that we at Caltech did
and I want to give before I start I want
to give a big shout out to my coworkers
in particular Robert Wong he's an
amazing PhD student and he did all of
the numerix I'm going to show you later
and Trump rascal is also an amazing
co-worker and his insights and
suggestions helped us a lot to kind of
do actually interesting numerical
demonstrations so my talk is going to be
about exactly overcoming this
exponential bottleneck that is
associated with quantum state tomography
at least in certain scenarios so we are
going to be interested in finding
tractable and efficient techniques on
predicting properties like linear or
quadratic functions in an unknown
quantity
and the goal we have in mind is to make
these ideas give them a sound
theoretical underpinning but we also
really want to branch out to
experimentalists and the main result of
this talk will be a nice ready
prediction for a proposal that actually
works with estar it calls them local
local measurements so I find this very
exciting and here's a brief outline of
my talk I first want to give a brief
motivation and briefly sketch existing
approaches to the problem of parameter
estimation and I'm really really happy
that David just gave an excellent talk
before me because he actually took care
of a lot of the motivation and existing
approaches namely state tomography and
then I will do something very very
theoretical because I will assume a very
very general measurement model and then
kind of reason about how we could use
such a measurement model to predict a
large collection of linear functions so
please bear with me this might be a bit
theoretical a bit abstract
there will be formulas but once we have
the main theorem the general theorem
ready and looking forward to jumping
into concrete examples and the first
example will be computational basis
measurements that are kind of preceded
by a global Clifford circuit so I think
in David's language that would be local
global because we do single copy
measurements but we do global
pre-processing and the second example
will be local Clifford for circuits
followed by computational basis
measurements and this is a local local
measurement procedure and after we've
gathered these results there will also
be some numerix I briefly want to talk a
bit about optimality it turns out that
without imposing additional assumptions
these two example approaches are
actually information theoretical optimal
and then once we've properly understood
how to predict linear functions
I mean linear functions are very
important in quantum mechanics but we
are also interested in certain
polynomials like subsystem rainy and
trapeze for instance and it turns out
that our approach naturally generalizes
to decision
and then finally if I have the time I
want to quickly talk about the
randomization of our protocol and then
there will be a conclusion so here very
very broadly speaking let me zoom out
again I know David talked a lot about
that but the task of my talk will be we
assume that we have an unknown quantum
state and we can generate copies and
then we can maybe evolve it a bit apply
a certain gate set or something to like
kind of transform it and then we can do
measurements and the task is to make
predictions about this unknown
underlying quantum state and this is a
very very challenging goal because first
of all there's the curse of
dimensionality if we are interested in n
cubed systems then a complete classical
strict description of this quantum state
is a 2 to the N by 2 to the n matrix so
it's humongous there's a lot of degrees
of freedom and second of all I will also
assume strong measurements so once we
apply a measurement we get a classical
outcome but the density matrix is
heavily perturbed and I will actually
assume that it ceases to exist so if I
choose to measure the state is gone and
so in order to overcome this problem we
have to repeat individual measurements
many many times and then we'll have to
record outcomes and these have to be
stored in classical memory and then
afterwards we can maybe use these
observed measurement outcomes to compute
estimators or predictors for the things
we are actually interested in and for
the scope of today's talk I actually
want to treat these different challenges
separately so that we I want to divide
the required resources into the sample
complexity which is how many repetitions
of my experiment do I need adaptive on
all adaptive in order to have sufficient
data then I also want to kind of single
out the quantum hardware how complicated
are the unitary evolutions or channels I
have to apply before I do a simple
measurement and then of course we have
to throw the data and it better be
easier
efficient to store because otherwise we
run out of storage and finally I also
want to comment and treat classical
post-processing so the actual
computation that takes the store data
and transforms it into a prediction of
what we're interested in separately and
so the task is to make predictions from
quantum measurements and I also want to
kind of work in the local setting where
we do single state copy measurements
only and one proposed solution actually
the classical solution to this problem
is to just learn the complete classical
description of the underlying quantum
state that's a D by DT density matrix
and that's of course quantum state
tomography and David talked a lot about
this and gave some excellent review
about things that happen here I just
quickly want to like to set the stage
list the four different resources we
have to consider and estaba to pointed
out the sampling rate for quantum state
tomography necessarily scales in the big
Hilbert space dimension which might be
exponentially large there's nice
information theoretical lower bounds and
if we actually want to predict a large D
by D matrix it shouldn't surprise us
that the number of samples has to scale
at least kind of linearly in the rank
and then linearly in the ambient
dimension and as you know to actually
put a square in the rank here because
I'm looking at similarly single copy
measurements turn right and Rhyno Donal
as well as Shawn muha and others among
arrow marrow could show that if you had
the possibility to do intended
measurements across many copies you
could get a single rank vector here and
then the quantum hardware that's the
redeeming factor of of quantum state
tomography at least to some extent as
David pointed out can sometimes be
tractable or rather easy Dobby talked
about local local measurements but the
recovery guarantee he kept in mind here
actually requires kayford circuits so
clifford circuits at least only
polynomially big but they do require
entangling gates so I wouldn't call that
technically very very tractable
incurring these devices and then to
round it off
classical storage is well the size of
the density matrix to save and the
classical prose processing time of this
projected least-squares actually have in
mind here is order dimension to the
power of four and here I want you like
to stress that this is for general rank
our quantum state tomography and if you
are willing to impose additional
assumptions on a state there might be
considerable improvements for example if
you are very confident that the
underlying state is well described by
matrix product state with low bond
dimension then you can actually recover
such a matrix product state description
with severe with substantially fewer
measurements actually polynomial I mean
this is something that David worked on
and more recently which is more for
heuristics but it also seems to work
very well new deep neural networks if
you train them on measurement outcomes
then they eristic
seem to be able to actually predict a
lot of properties of the underlying
state reliably and so it is also
possible to view your network tomography
as kind of a specialized approach of
quantum state tomography on the other
end of the spectrum is something that's
called shadow tomography and it dates
back to John to Scott Aaronson and was
proven in this case and the task here is
to like really rethink maybe the general
solution of quantum state tomography
because quantum state tomography gives
you a complete classical description
which is exponentially expensive and so
it answers all possible questions but
maybe we actually don't have to learn
the full classical description but it is
enough to predict certain features and
for the first part of my talk I actually
want to restrict my attention to linear
features and Scott Aaronson does
precisely met so Scott Aaronson
considers the problem of predicting
linear functions that I wrote here as
tracing our product with some
observables or one 2om and you just want
to accurately predict a collection of
pizzette possibly very many linear
functions but you don't have to learn
the full density matrix
and then Aronson and later Aronson and
both Blum found a beautiful protocol
that showed that if you are only
interested in predicting M such
functions then a sampling rate that is
kind of poorly logarithmic in the number
of predictions and only poorly
logarithmic in the ambient pitch
dimension and there's like some epsilon
dependency on the accuracy only these
many copies of Rho suffice to actually
epsilon accurately clicked all of these
prophets properties simultaneously and I
find this very exciting because again
the number of predictions only enters
Polly logarithmically and the ambient
dimension enters logarithmically and so
if we have n qubits then 2 to the n
square becomes N squared in this case
like it's a very very nice theoretical
result but the underlying procedure is
actually non-trivial and I don't want to
go into details but if you actually want
to run this procedure there's big
demands on the quantum hardware you
actually need a corner memory and you
have to apply exponentially long
circuits to tens of products kind of
like gift store all your copies in
memory and then apply exponentially long
quantum circuits to this plain big
tensor product and also the storage is
exponentially large and it's not
entirely classical and the post
processing time is pork also scales in a
big dimension and it's all also not
entirely classical but of course the
sampling rate result I think is really
really interesting and of course Scott
is not the first person to consider the
problem of predicting linear target
functions there's like a wealth of
existing ideas in the literature I just
want to like pretty quickly point to two
such procedures that will be revelant
relevant for our talk today and this is
like direct fidelity estimation a very
nice procedure that flaminia and view
developed and also bridges at our in in
Spock
came up with a nice protocol for
predicting
subsystem containment entropies at once
we'll see those later
we sure have a quick question yes maybe
I don't know Scott's up line but this
exponential complexity or the processing
and storage is this believed to be
inherent like there are states or like
the distribution of states for which I I
think just like the general procedure
the weight is framed out maybe Scott can
chime in why you know you test these
requirements oh hi yeah do you want me
to address that I mean so so the answer
is first of all you know if you need to
store the state like a description of
the state that's already you know DS
squared complexity right if you you know
need to write down all the answers
that's already a mess now what you could
hope for is that the data would be given
to you implicit ly you know in some like
circuit representation and then your
output would also be implicit and in
that in that case we have some evidence
that there are inherent computational
limits in particular if you could always
do it computationally efficiently then
you could always simulate you could
always replace quantum advice by
classical advice yeah well so like PQ p
/q poly would equal B QP / poly okay and
you know also like you know I mean there
were there would be a few other strange
consequences like I guess you know
they're like the for like quantum
copy-protection quantum money things
like that I would love to know better
the complexity theory situation okay
great thank you so much for chiming in
and clarifying this excellent okay
so again really really beautiful
protocol but it seems a bit too
demanding to run it on current nice
device and maybe
new devices and so this but the stopping
rate is amazing and so this motivated
asked us to asked the following kind of
general question and we can we find a
tractable and rigorous procedure that
kind of achieves something similar to
Scott's procedure maybe we have to of
course we will have to make compromises
because we want to use weaker tools and
kind of be a bit more near term and so
maybe we can't predict kind of
efficiently predict an arbitrary
collection of linear functions but maybe
some some relevant ones and so what we
want to find is intractable and rigorous
procedure that kind of learns a
classical representation of an unknown
quantum states from few simple single
copy measurements so kind of a ideas we
perform first we perform simple single
single copy measurements and then we get
some measurement data and we use this
measurement data to construct the
classical representation and ideally we
should be able to use this classical
representation that can be efficiently
stored on our classical computer to
predict many linear and maybe even
polynomial properties in a way that is
similar to what Scott wants to do but
for us we really want to have a heart
kind of like a heart divided between an
unknown quantum system and the single
copy measurements we do and then we are
in the classical world and we just want
to like do classical computations with
the measurement outcomes that we stored
okay and now I'm I think after this
motivation I'm ready to talk about the
ideas and the approach that we found and
again please bear with me I will be very
general in the beginning but to and
derive a very general result and then we
will make that a lot more concrete for
looking at two very relevant examples
okay so here is the measurement setup
that we envision again so kind of we
assume that there is an underlying
unknown quantum state let's say it's on
n qubits the wires represent the qubits
and we assume that we can make
independent copies of the state and then
we assume that we are able to kind of
or from an ensemble of unitary circuits
so kind of we have an ensemble of
unitary circuits that we can efficiently
implement in our measurements and we
sample one element of the circuit family
at random we apply it to row and then we
modify the stage and then afterwards we
perform a sync single tensor product
computational basis measurement so after
this this unitary evolution we measure
the first qubit energy basis the second
qubit energy basis and so on until the
end cubed cubed in the C basis and what
we end up with is a bit string of length
N and now our idea is kind of like this
observed bit string of length n is
somehow correlated with the input state
because of bonds rule and we also have
to take into account the unitary
transformation in the middle and so we
can just use the bit string that we
observed map it to a computational basis
state a rank one state and then attach
the unitary evolution on the left and on
the right in order to remember kind of
what we did be prior to the
computational basis measurement and now
what you can see here very generally is
we have a quantum state that comes in
and we have a quantum state that comes
out with the difference that like this
on the right hand side where in
classical world so this features the bit
string that we actually measured and a
classical description of the unitary
nevertheless we can kind of view kind of
the map that takes a quantum state
applies a random unitary from our Sorbo
then takes a computational basis
measurement and looks at the post
measurement state is a nice quantum
channel and in expectation because
there's like randomness involved first
of all we choose our unitary evolution
at random and second of all the
computational basis measurement how
comes in a single shot are also random
and so let's just look at the expected
kind of like the expected post
measurement state and then we can just
insert the definitions and kind of
first singling out like kind of the
classical randomness that we put in kind
of an expectation value overall unit
Aires in our Samba and then he have just
plucked in Bonjour so kind of there's
two to the N different computational
basis states and the probability of
measuring each of them is given by bones
rule and it would really just be B u Rho
u dagger cat cat B yes and this actually
defines a quantum Channel it's not so
difficult to check that and this bottom
channel is actually kind of nice
it's trace preserving it's completely
positive and it's also self adjoint and
interestingly and it shouldn't come as a
surprise to the experts among you this
channel this expected channel is
invertible if the course or board from
which we sample is sufficiently
expressive to cover all of state space
in other words if like the collection of
all the measurements that could be could
implement in this fashion is to more
graphically complete and let's for now
assume that this is the case because if
this channel is invertible well the
inverse might not be a quantum Channel
it's typically not positive
semi-definite but we are anyway on our
output already in classical world and
maybe we can do it classically and so in
order kind of like if you perform one of
these measurements once we get cannot
let a measurement outcome and we can
associate this post measurement States
state with it classically and then we
can in principle just invert this
channel on this post measurement state
because it's all happening on our
computer and once we do that obviously
by construction this row head is a
random matrix this should be heads here
sorry I forgot them so I kind of the
copied computational basis that we
observe is random and the unitary is
random but by construction this random
matrix is is the correct underlying
density matrix in expectation and this
is actually the starting point of our
idea and our approach to predict many
linear features at once because we will
just like enough like
this is a classical description and
whenever we want to predict the linear
function we will replace the underlined
state which we don't know by one of
these snapshots or an average of these
snapshots because then we will be
correct in expectation and each of these
snapshots might be an independent random
matrix and then we get rapid convergence
and so a classical shadow collects M
independent snapshots so envision that I
run this experiment in many times and
then I will get n different random
outcomes so like for each measurement
that will probably see a different bit
string as an outcome and I will probably
sample a different unitary and so
classical shadows just collect n
independent snapshots and again by
construction these are all independent
random matrices instances of a random
matrix that are in expectation are
exactly the underlying quantum state
they are however not density matrices
themselves necessarily because we've
inverted the quantum channel here and
that's typically not was a completely
positive okay and now we can get started
and let's start with something easy
let's try to predict a single linear
property so similar to like Scott's
approach but he does many let's just do
one for now how can we predict one
linear function with a classical shadow
of size M and remember these are these
independent snapshots that equal the
true underlying density matrix in
expectation so well let's just use this
because I could in principle take my
first classical shadow its classical a
classical description of my observable
oh let's ignore computation costs for
now and take the trace in a product and
then I will get a number and by
construction of my classical shadow this
number will be the actual true function
in expectation and now with my classical
shadow I don't only have one such random
matrix that I can turn into a random
number with correct expectation by that
and of them
and so a natural answer is to boost
convergence to this desired expectation
value by taking the sample means of all
my independent snapshots and we already
know that this is correcting expectation
and we can bound the convergence by
using chebyshev's inequality like one of
the most simple ideas that allow you to
kind of reason about random variables
and chebyshev's inequality tells us that
the probability of the sample mean
estimator deviating by more than epsilon
from the true desire target is bounded
by the variance of an individual random
number in our sum over the desired
accuracy squared and yeah there
shouldn't be a delta T actually that's a
typo and now we just have to understand
what this variance is and let me just
like quickly write it out the variance
is by definition the expectation of the
square of the random variable minus the
square of the expectation and it's like
some small trick here but kind of since
we subtract the square of the
expectation we can actually upper bound
this by the expectation of a tray
squared but not of the original target
function but of its traceless part this
is kind of a general feature about
variances because we subtract
expectation values and so we can
restrict ourselves to traceless the
trace is part of the observable here and
now kind of like we have an expectation
of something we already understood but
with a square and we can insert the
definition of a classical shadow so this
looks a bit brutal right now but I've
really just kind of concerted the
definition of a classical shadow and did
some minor modulations and so we again
have like the expectation value over the
unitary ensemble that we pick off we
have a sum over the possible
computational basis outcome States we
have kind of a way in fact that it
depends on the underlying state and the
important thing here is that we have
this inverse measurement channel but now
apply to the trace
is observable and then rotated by the
unitary and then in a product with the
computational basis states squared and
this is actually kind of like a
not-so-nice property because you can see
that it explicitly depends on the
underlying state and kind of when i want
to get a priori bounds i never want to
like be dependent on the actual
underlying state which i don't know and
so I can find a further upper bound by
replacing the state by the maximum over
all possible states this is certainly an
upper bound and what you actually can
also check is that this expression on
the right for any unitary ensemble
defines a squared norm because maybe
like this is kind of like a weighting
factor some of weighting factors this is
just an expectation and here we have
kind of like square squared matrix
entries on some diagonal and so this
defines an esquire squared norm very
very generally and this norm depends on
the measurement ensemble that we use but
not on the underlying state anymore and
now we actually have a lemma just with
chebyshev's inequality namely that the
shadow norm squared characterizes the
necessary classical shadow size to the
necessary number of independent
measurement repetitions we need to
ensure that we predict our single linear
function
upto accuracy epsilon with high
probability and the number of samples is
really just this shadow norm of the
traceless observable over a desired
accuracy squared or x probability of
failure Delta so so far so easy but now
oh I'm sorry this should be Oh bah and
that's again the faceless part it's just
a traceless part of the observable we
can't which kind of makes sense because
suppose that we were to we wanted to
predict the trace of an identity matrix
then we know that it's 1 and kind of a
reasonable and the traceless part of the
identity matrix is 0 because we kind of
don't need a single sample to actually
reason that the trace of identity matrix
is thanks for pointing that out
and now let's kind of switch gears just
a little bit it's not going to get much
more complicated to like ask the
question about can we also predict many
linear properties this is really one of
the exciting things of Scott's protocol
that he can just predict it n different
in your target functions with just
poorly logarithmic leave many
measurements and so let's try to do that
as well so kind of we want to now not
predict the single observable but M of
them and think M of being a potentially
large number but we want to predict all
of them with the same classical shadow
with the same collection of random
snapshots from our simple measurement
and then like the naive idea is kind of
like let's just stick to the sample mean
estimator that we had before and just
apply a Union bound so kind of now for
each oh I I just used the sample mean
estimator and here it should actually be
a sum over the rows and then we can
actually use a Union bound to check how
large the probability is that at least
one of them the maximum deviates by more
than epsilon according to the Union
bound I gain effect of M this is scary
because it's a potentially large number
but I can pull the maximum outside and
now I'm kind of in the single prediction
regime again and if I just kind of
insert the insights from
Bishop's inequality I cannot get a
maximum a maximum shadow norm squared
here over epsilon squared and then I get
an M / probability over failure
probability but this is actually kind of
really bad because it tells me that the
number of samples I need in order to
predict M properties actually scales
linearly and and kind of that the rest
is just very reminiscent of what we had
before but like this linear scaling is
like very very different from what Scott
Aaronson achieved and so we probably
have to think a bit harder and there's a
better idea actually of kind of solving
these kinds of problems and its median
of means estimation it's like a very
simple beautiful trick that dates back a
long time ago and I think the brother of
image was Ronnie who is an organizer
here was one of the inventors of this
and the idea is very simple again
actually it's really cute instead of
like kind of collect constructing a
single collection of random snapshots
and using all of them to predict a
single sample mean you kind of data
splitting and create kind of like K
batches capital K batches so like you
take a few more measurements but then
you construct K different classical
shadows it's like kind of really instead
of like just using one sample mean you
kind of like construct K different
batches and then you construct K
associated sample means for each of the
properties that I'm interested in so
here in the first line we're interested
in just predicting the first observable
and so I use the first batch to compute
a sample mean associated with my first
prediction and then I use the second
batch to construct a linearly
independent one and I go on and then I
used a cave batch to construct yet
another sample mean and then rather than
taking the mean of them I take the
median so kind of I take a median of
sample means and I do this
same for all different properties that
I'm interested in predicting so there's
m of them and the trick is not that we
is really just this median of means
Drake is very powerful because now we
can go back to our probability bound
like what is the probability that a
maximum deviation is larger greater
equal than epsilon I again do a Union
bound to pull the maximum outside I have
to pay a factor of M but this time I
don't care so much because here I am
again like kind of in a single in a
single prediction procedure and now here
is whether median does it's magic
because o I is now a median of K
different sample means and we know that
the average expectation of each sample
mean is or I and so when does a median
of random variables deviate them more
than epsilon from its target well in
order to do so at least half of all the
sample means have to be deviate from
their expectation value but more than
epsilon at least half of them and this
becomes exponentially unlikely in the
number of sample means that we consider
and so unlike before you now get
actually now an additional like this
looks very similar to what we saw before
but we get an additional exponential
suppression in the number of batches K
and this actually does the trick and it
tells us that if we take there a total
of like maximal shadow norm squared over
X is our target actually squared for
each of our batches and the total number
of batches is logarithmic in the number
of predictions we want to make then we
can actually ensure that we get all of
them up to actual accuracy epsilon with
very high probability and this now only
scales logarithmically in the number of
measurements and is actually the main
result of our work so kind of for our
general result remember again that we
started with a very simple single copy
measurement procedure where we kind of
have a measurement primitive named
that we sample a unitary rotation from
an ensemble and this defines a
measurement channel and we can use this
average measurement channel to define
our snapshots which are just like kind
of the post measurement States stored
classically and then invert it and then
apply and then kind of apply the inverse
of the channel to ensure that it has the
right expectation value and then our our
discussion about statistical convergence
also motivated the definition of this
shadow norm which also depends on a
measurement primitive and now receive
these three very general concepts in
mind here is the main theorem that we
have actually just proved so suppose we
are interested in predicting M fixed
linear target properties in an unknown
state row then a classical shadow of
size like the number of measurements we
need to build this collection of
classical shadows is numb the total
number is number of measurements per
patch times the number of patches and
this indeed scales logarithmically in
the number of predictions it's taeil's
inverse poetically in the desired
accuracy and there also features the
maximum of all shadow notes and once we
have this larger collection of our
classical shape snapshots then we can
predict all properties via median of
means estimation with very high
probability let me emphasize again that
this sample complexity this number of
measurements depends only
logarithmically on the number of
predictions you want to make and it's
the shadow norm not the huge ambient
dimension that determines the cost so
there's no dimension factor here yet it
might pop up with the shadow norm
okay Irish are there any questions at
this level yeah you say some more about
this shadow non like what's the range of
it and um maybe can we postpone this
because in my experience also for me
personally this
the shadow gnome became a lot more
graspable when looking at examples okay
but thank you okay now this is a very
general result it's probably too general
to like convey much intuition but I
still believe it's kind of powerful and
in order to demonstrate this let us do
like maybe the slickest example that I
can think of that we could think of and
the example we want to consider first a
global plea for circuits so we again
have like the measurement setup that I
discussed before we have an unknown
quantum state and now we assume that we
are able to apply arbitrary Clifford
circuits to it and not only arbitrary
four circuits that we actually sample a
random cliff fourth circuit and apply to
the state and then we perform a
computational basis measurement and then
once we do that we can record a bit
string we remember the clifford we
applied and we construct for store the
post measurement state you take a peek
at B bra you on our classical computer
and then it's actually possible to like
really find very nice closed form
expressions of all a rather abstract
properties that I discussed before and
it's all thanks to the fact that the
cliff for group at least for n qubits
forms a 3d design this will allow us to
compute these things actually now here
let's first look at the measurement
channel which is kind of and he now an
average over the full Clifford group of
a son and now here you can probably see
that you features twice and u dagger
Fisher's voice and now the fact that the
Clifford groups form is a to design
allows us to replace this property by an
integral over the full unitary group
that's the definition of a to design and
you can actually use your while duality
to compute that and in the end what you
will find is that the expected
measurement channel is really just a
depolarizing channel and the
depolarization parameter is one of our
dimension plus one and depolarizing
channels are like kind of really nice in
particular it's very easy to invert
and so kind of the classical shadow is
the inverse measurement channel applied
to our post measurement state and this
is really just dimension plus one time's
the post measurements that we observed
minus the identity and if we ignore the
identity matrix for a moment note that
this is actually proportional to a
stabilizer state because it's a
computational basis state and we apply a
Clifford unitary to it and this is good
news for storage we can actually store
these these guys efficiently and finally
let's talk a bit about the shadow norm
in the shadow norm we again have an
average over the key for group but now
we have an additional square here and if
you were to count the unitary you
appears three times and the unitary u
dagger also appears three times and we
now also have an inverse depolarizing
channel here which kind of introduces
potentially scary dimension factors but
the fact that the Clifford group forms
also a three design allows us to replace
this average with an interpreter for the
harm measure the full unitary group and
then we can again use your wide or
allottee to actually compute it and it's
possible to obtain a rather simple upper
bound which is just three times
the Hilbert Schmidt norm squared of the
observable that we started with so for
the measurement primitive four we apply
global clifford circuits the measurement
channel is a depolarizing channel the
classical shadow is a scaled version of
a stabilizer state and the shadow norm
squared is really proportional to the
hilbert smith norm squared and here's
maybe like just a simple intuition about
why this might be the case and here's a
vivid visualization of a stabilizer
measurement so kind of like in a rebate
there's only two different there's only
two cliff forts and there's like the
computational based it isn't the
plus/minus basis and suppose we have a
state that hides somewhere here then if
we do make sure this measurement like
the PM associated with these four
measurements the
note that these guys and these guys will
be more likely to fly - to occur than
the ones that are further away and so if
you kind of like just use that and form
an empirical average of like all
possible kind of like itches like kind
of average the outcomes then you will at
some point get exactly the measurement
channel the average channel in the limit
of infinite repetitions and you can
probably see visually here that it's
really just a map that takes row and
pulls it inward and this is exactly what
the polarizing channel does and this
intuition extends to arbitrary powers of
two
with this we have a corollary of our
main result which is hopefully a bit
more graspable suppose we are actually
in this regime where we can like apply a
random Clifford unitary followed by a
computational basis measurement then
classical shadows kind of the inverse
throat slightly modified post
measurement states
pleskot shadows of a total size the dis
logo with make in the number of
predictions we want to make scales
inverse political unit inside accuracy
and scales proportional to the maximum
here but Schmidt norm squared of the
things we want to predict suffice to
predict M linear target properties be a
median of leads and so the sampling rate
is independent of the dimension but it
actually scales with the hilbert smith
norm and this can be good or this can be
bad for instance if you're interested in
direct fidelity estimation like Steve
Flemmi and he can you were then our
target is really just a pure state and
the hilbert smith norm is one and we can
deduce that if we were just interested
in a single direct fidelity then a
number of samples a number of
measurement repetition is just inverse
proportional to the desired accuracy
squared actually surfaces on the other
hand if we're interested in predicting
and observable like x on every qubit
then a total number of measurements has
to scale exponentially in a number of
qubit qubits because the hilbert smith
norm of an observer was huge and
locality doesn't help you on the quantum
hardware site kind of like the procedure
only requires key for circuits in
computational basis measurements so
clifford circuits only a polynomial
depth but they still require entangling
gates so there might still be a bit
challenging to implement in today's
devices but the classical storage is
pretty good because we only have to
store stabilizer states or slight
motivation step off and the classical
post-processing cost is actually
dominated by the cost for computing an
overlap between the stabilizer States we
stored and the predictions we want to
make so that's also pretty good and
applications has indicated already a
pure fidelity estimation
you can also actually use this protocol
to predict many entanglement witnesses
at once if you want to certify or detect
in tournament
here's a quick numerical experiment that
kind of demonstrates that this works and
it should also be like a stylus proof of
concepts that these ideas can at least
in theory scale and the underlying state
the unknown state we consider is a
noiseless or a noisy GHC state on n
qubits and be very N and the target it's
a bit uncreated but just consider that
as a proof of principle is the quantum
fidelity with a noiseless THC state and
in these numerix we actually compared
with neural network quantum state
tomography which recently gained a lot
of traction which is heuristics a pro/5
so fast
heuristic approach that seems to scale
well in the number of qubits and on the
left-hand side we plot on the x axis the
number of qubits in the ghz state so we
go from 0 to more than 120 and on the y
axis we denote the number of experiments
the number of measurement repetitions or
the size of the classical shadow that is
required to achieve an 0.99 fidelity
with the noise legit is that given that
we actually measure and whether Jesse's
dead and what you can see here is kind
of like just a very fair a support for
our theorem the number of measurements
we need to do is completely independent
of the ambient dimension while neural
network quantum state tomography skates
linearly with the number of qubits and
on the right hand side we did a small
twist we actually didn't consider an
underlying noiseless THC state but a THC
stated his subject to a face flip and
here on the x-axis is the probability of
a face flip and here on the y-axis you
find the estimated fidelity with a
noiseless GHz state and you can see the
kind of feature predicted prediction
with classical shadows really tracks the
linear decay in these fidelity's
ok so far which can ask a question
okay hey this is David speaking so
before I go on so of course now we know
that if we don't have random Clifford's
but if you have random clifford's with a
system size independent number of TJ
thrown in the lesson Garrity design oh
yeah would that help you at all not
really kind of we actually worked out
that you randomize it to get it down to
three designs using the median of mean
streak and so kind of like if you were
to like kind of like as an extreme
example if you wanted to let just
compute the required number of
measurements or data points you need to
do median of means prediction with the
haar measure then the analysis would be
completely equivalent to the Clifford
case and maybe the shadow norm could be
smaller or something like that song no
they said a normal kind of the way you
compute is you really use the three
design property and you kind of equate
it to the haar measure to the higher
average because it only requires three
moments and then your they already all
right okay so I guess I should have
waited for your optimality chapter then
yes um I think what happens of course is
actually if you were able to do her any
minute Ares then we could get rid of the
median of mean streak you could just
take a sample mean and concentration of
measure will tell you that this works
out fine yeah that seems like a minor
potential advantage okay but yeah thanks
for the question but that kind of the
shadow norm is completely identical for
her any military's
okay so globally foot measurements
actually kind of conceptually nice like
all the properties that are involved
I become depolarizing channels or he
birch mid-tones so it's actually kind of
fun to reason about them but of course
they have the problem that in order to
implement a random Clifford circuits you
have to do in tenían gates and in tenon
gates are pretty challenging and so let
us go to our second main example which
is local play for circuits so now I
again assume that I have an in cubed
system but instead of like being able to
apply a big random Clifford I only apply
allow local random Clifford unitary
state act on one qubit exclusively
followed by a computational basis
measurement and just note that kind of
this measurement primitive is actually
equivalent to a local local measurement
technique that David talked about where
you can basically measure in random
polar basis that's kind of like the
computational basis just to see basis in
a random Clifford unitary rotates can
rotate it to an X or Y basis so kind of
like the local Clifford circuit
measurement primitive is just totally
basis measurements and so we assume that
we can do this and then we record the
post measurement state classically and
because everything is local here our
classical snapshots or post measurement
or post measurement States actually
factorize decompose completely into
tensor product which is a very very nice
property that hopefully already alludes
to some of the potential applications of
this entire procedure we will see that
it is very well suited for predicting
local properties and so you can actually
just use the trick from the global
Clifford computations that I mentioned
before to also apply it here but on a
local level so in order to make the
computation of the average measurement
channel easier let me assume that I have
a tensor product state like linear
linear extension will allow me to
reasonable
arbitrary states but this makes it
easier if I have if I apply this average
measurement channel to attends a product
state then everything factorizes
completely I get a big tensor product on
the outside and everything inside is
actually a two dimensional variant of
the global random Clifford computation
that we already did and we already know
what this expected measurement channel
is it's a depolarizing channel and the
parameter is one or what dimension plus
one which is in this case one third and
then because we have a big tensor
product we have an n-fold tensor product
of that so kind of also the measurement
channel X locally it is local
depolarizing channels on each of the
qubits and now they depolarize a kind of
like the classical shadow or a snapshot
that we want to store is the post
measurement state that we observe and
then we apply the inverse channel but
because these factorizes into tensor
product and this factorizes into tensor
product the entire truss the entire
classical snapshot is just itself kind
of not a tensor product state because
it's not positive semi-definite but it
attends a product of very very simple
objects and note that if I were to trace
out kind of like each local constituent
here has unit trace so I can actually
like trace out parts of this classical
shadow that I'm not interested in and
last but not least I'm not going to do
it here but we can also find relatively
tight bounds on the shadow norm and it
turns out that the shadow norm scales
exponentially near locality of the
target function I'm interested in so if
my target only acts non-trivial II let's
say on 10 cubits doesn't matter where
they are then the shadow Nam can be
upper bounded by four to the ten times
the operator norm squared of this
property and operator norms of
observables are typically bounded by one
and here locality of all religious
measures the number of qubits on which
all X non-trivial and so this is
like very very different from the global
Clifford measurement primitives that we
saw and but I just invoking the main
theorem I showed before we can conclude
the classical shadows of this total size
based on a local Clifford measurement
primitives like really independent
random poorly measurements suffice to
predict M linear target properties via
median of means with high probability
and again now kind of like it's
logarithmic in the number of predictions
and the number of samples now scales
exponentially in your locality but is
again independent of the ambient
dimension and so if we're interested in
predicting local observables then this
is good news because the number of
samples we need really only scales
exponentially in the locality but if you
are interested in non-local observables
then the total number of samples we need
with this procedure is actually actually
exponentially large now the quantum
hardware here I think it's really kind
of we approaching an Iskra team because
it's really just being able to measure
random poly bases for each new data
point the classical storage is also very
benign like we also we only have to
store product states essentially there
are also stabilizer States and if we're
interested in classical post-processing
we have to compute overlaps between
these states and the observer was and
this is dominated by the largest
locality because we can just trace out
the part that we don't care about and
possible applications are kind of more
physical properties like K point
correlators or like energy of local
Hamiltonians or like Hamiltonians that
are comprised of sums a sense of local
observables and let me quickly show some
numerix here so here we again compare
our ideas mainly linear feature
prediction with classical shadows and
random poly measurements or local
Clifford measurements with neural
network quantum state tomography which
gained a lot of traction and here we
assume in this first America assume that
the underlying state is the ground state
of
be critical anti-aromatic
antiferromagnetic transverse field Ising
model these models are interesting
because they have only a polynomial
decay of correlations and we want to
show that and so the target is like now
we want to predict many features maybe
all two point functions that collect
connect the first site with all the
other sites in a lattice of size 50 and
here you can see kind of the results the
blue line is the true value value
analytically obtained by doing geometry
or MPs approximations and you can see
the classical shadows and neural network
tomography kind of nicely track that and
both use the same number of random
polling measurements so kind of this is
a fair comparison and you can see there
are roughly roughly comparable now as a
second numerix we can go to
two-dimensional lattice models so we
consider the two-dimensional
antiferromagnetic Heisenberg the ground
state of that Heisenberg model on an 8x8
lattice kind of geometry becomes
challenging if you go to 2d system and
the target is again all two point
functions in this Heisenberg model and
we again compare with no network quantum
state tomography and here you can see
kind of what this correlation table it's
not 2-dimensional because we can go in
two directions should look like
according to the emoji which we consider
to be analytically and here you can see
what new network quantum state
tomography delivers and here you see
feature prediction with classical
shadows and median of means and you can
see they are all pretty similar it's
actually difficult to spot differences
but there's maybe a few more
hallucinations down here but again the
methods are comparable where they really
start to become different is if we do a
runtime comparison so kind of neural
network quantum state tomography is
faced and like doing these measurements
and using these measurements to tray aim
a deep neural network and this to keep
neural network is then used as a
classical representation of the
underlying quantum state and typically
training your network is not cheap
whereas kind of
the prediction procedure that we propose
is really just remember the measurements
outcomes you have you had like two minor
modifications there off and then take
sample averages and maybe medians of
sample averages so everything is apart
from the median everything is linear
there and you can actually see this in
this plot that the the run time between
classical shadow prediction or network
state tomography
is rather extreme namely you can see
here for the numerical experiments that
I showed earlier there's roughly and 10
to the 4 different difference in
classical post-processing time seconds
which shouldn't come as a surprise but
the results both methods give our
brother comparable okay now let me very
very briefly talk about optimality
actually we have seen two concrete
examples for linear prediction with
classical shadows so kind of it kind of
just store the measurement outcome you
use it to form the post measurement
States on your classical computer and
then you invert the measurement channel
to get something that is correct an
expectation and we saw that kind of if
we have a global Clifford measurement
primitives so we are able to do random
global efforts in the middle then a
number of samples we need to predict M
linear features scales with the huge
budget with the largest team budget
click none of these features and then we
also so loco Clifford measurements and
there the number of samples required to
Greek linear function scales
exponentially in the locality and while
these things might make sense it's a
natural question to ask are these
sampling rates necessary and in order to
answer this question I quickly want to
point out that linear prediction with
classical shadows has two core
properties given that is a very very
naive or a simple procedure first of all
let me reinstall we assume single copy
measurements so
copies of the quantum state measured
independently and then the second
features maybe a bit more crucial and
it's not necessarily I may be a bit too
naive but
data acquisition is also oblivious and
ignorant with respect to the predictions
you actually want to make so kind of
iffy assumed the local Clifford
measurement setup then like kind of the
data acquisition phases we just choose a
random perturbation basis measure it
once get the bit string
remember the Polly matrix and then
repeat this is completely independent of
the actual predictions we want to make
and it's also normal active and you can
actually show that any linear prediction
technique that is based on oblivious so
kind of previous it's a universal
independent measurement data acquisition
phases that are also based on singing
copy measurements kind of require an
order of state copies to achieve the
prediction task that is exactly
comparable with the upper bounds we got
for our feature prediction with job
global Clifford measurements and if you
actually also instantiate that you want
to do local measurements so kind of only
singing qubit rotations that are also
oblivious and only act on single copies
then it can show that the number of
state copies that is required to
accurately predict a worst-case
collection of M observables also scales
box exponentially in the locality and
correctly in your platinum but note that
here the lower bound is a free to the
locality where's our upper bound is only
a four to the locality so there's a
small gap and I don't want to say too
much about the proof idea it's actually
pretty standard we are inspired by
relating feature prediction of M
different observables to a task in
quantum communication complexity so
suppose that such an such a device
existed that can predict M features very
very accurately then it could use that
to transfer information by encoding a
list could for example in called
classical information into n qubits
send it to Bob and Bob could then use
this hypothetical device to kind of
decode alice's message
and yes and kind of we this these ideas
go back to to David Krause and Steve
Lamia in 2012 and then they were later
refined by John Wuhan Aaron Harrow and
others to find title points for quantum
state tomography at the one twist we do
here is that actually we allow for kind
of a see me
mischievous agent that kind of randomly
rotates each cue at each quantum system
kind of it intersects he intercepted he
rotates it and then he forwards it to
Bob and he stays quiet but kind of after
the data acquisition phase on Bob side
is completed the mischievous agent
actually reveals his unitary to Bob and
this kind of pinpoints the difference
between an oblivious prediction
technique and a general tomographic
prediction technique because an
oblivious technique can handle such a
such as seeming mischievous agent
because even if the data is already
collected if the data acquisition
doesn't depend on the things you want to
predict you can kind of rotate your
codebook classically afterwards and
still decode the relevant information
and by doing this kind of a guess if you
can commit M bit then the mutual
information has to be log M and then it
has to pass through here and then you
can simplify enemy and what you will see
is that the lower bounds papa
the church's quick time warning yes how
much time do I have left - OH - a couple
of them in sorry I I don't ever time yet
so um merely very very very quickly you
can extend these ideas to predict
polynomial functions as well kind of the
entire idea generalizes and you have to
use you statistics and with this you can
predict Raney entanglement entropy of
subsystems and this works very very well
it's also very efficient and yeah
with that I actually want
rude and thank you for your attention
I'm sorry for going over time
alright thanks Richard so you know
please feel free to type in your
questions and while maybe people are
thinking about their questions I guess I
think I understand so it sounds like the
scheme you're proposed actually the
measurements that are performed are
independent of the predictions that you
want to yes so so somehow that seems you
know how can you say a little bit more
about how like why is the number of men
you know there's a dependence on a
number of measurements then because you
know you make this you make the shadow
but it should work in principle for for
any measurement you you walk up with
provided that the shadows are only small
you know it doesn't know in advance what
what measurements you're going to ask
about yes but kind of like yes that's
true but kind of a necessary condition
is that kind of you can first do the
data acquisition but our constructive
theoretical convergence guarantee is
only holde if the number of measurements
you actually did is proportional for
instance to the largest locality squared
this is just that kind of like for any
collection of same observables this
number suffices to ensure that you can
predict all of them accurately with high
probability but the precise nature of
these observables doesn't play a role so
if you let's say you know you picked a
sample a sample size like and and then
you ended up trying to predict more than
the requisite number yes a lot of number
of measurements it would like suddenly
fail you know I I actually I actually
don't think so just like kind of like
the constructive results failed to hold
at some point and it's a and also like
if the number of measurements are the
number of questions you ask becomes too
large the entire argument breaks down
because you could in principle like look
at the classical snapshots that I have
and kind of like at the linear
prediction technique that I use and kind
of like try to find directions in state
space where like my data is very very
bad and then it could start breaking it
so so there's a couple questions in the
Q&A but before I turn to them I think
maybe now's a good time to maybe a lot
of people take a break
so let's reconvene in deep and yeah so
so you know that's that's me to get at
12:50 Pacific and in the meantime let me
turn to the QA question so people are
asking about the D randomization
strategy so it's a few words about that
okay yeah of course um kind of on a high
level what this entire like key
randomization for local different
measurements so this addresses the nice
key case of like classical shadows from
local Clifford measurements where you
really do like kind of random body
measurements and then you record the
measurement outcome that you observed
and the unitary like kind of the basis
the poly basis that we measured in and
kind of what our result says is forget
for now the things you want to predict
kind of like just measure random poly
strings and if you measure sufficiently
many of them then with very high
probability you will be able to predict
many local properties at once okay this
is kind of like what what our main
result says and this can actually be
huge
it's a probabilistic result so with high
probability over all possible poorly
basis measurement collections I could do
it each step with high probability I
will get a measurement collection that
allows me to predict all of these local
properties simultaneously and kind of
just
probabilistic point of view this can be
viewed as an existence proof so because
if I randomly sample all my measurements
and I succeed with high probability it
means that there's like a deterministic
strategy that allows me to do that and
suppose now let's switch gears supposed
to we know the targets that we actually
want to compute then you can actually
use the method of pessimistic estimators
to D randomize the measurement procedure
completely and the idea behind that is
kind of like again let's assume we are
doing the first measurement kind of like
the first random measurements if we kind
of like in our original protocol we
sample the first poorly at random holy
bases at random second Adreno
third at random and our probablistic
guarantees tell that with high
probability a random collection will
yield great results but now I have three
choices for my first measurement X Y or
Z and our theoretical results tell me
that in F on average over all three
choices I will do well and now this in
particular tells me that there is a
particular choice either X or Y or Z the
kind of chiefs or like kind of that
achieves that also performs well or
maybe even performs better than a random
choice does this intuitively make sense
so there's kind of three choices for my
first measurement basis and our result
tells me tells us if we do it randomly
we will succeed with a high probability
and now we can start looking at
conditional expectation values like what
is the probability of predict accurately
predicting all targets given that I
chose X DX faces what is the probability
was the conditional expectation of
conditional probability of succeeding
accurately predicting all properties
given that I chose y and z and then
ideally one of these conditional
probabilities would be higher than the
others
and the method of pessimistic estimators
allow for making this precise and
turning it into an algorithm so kind of
at each local step where you have to
make a choice X Y or Z you kind of take
into account what you already did and
assume that everything from now on will
be done randomly what is the best choice
I can do now and this turns out to be
like kind of linear and a number of
qubits and you can you can you can you
can compute it
I mean you end up with a pessimist with
a deterministic measurement procedure
that performs at least as well as the
random guarantees that we derived but in
practice it performs much much better it
kind of gives you an additional 10 times
improvement in sample complexity
empirically so we have another question
hi sorry I guess you didn't have time to
talk about this nonlinear or polynomial
quantities so do you have an estimate
for the say drainie entropies for purity
I think in terms of the number of
measurements and so on yes yes yes
absolutely kind of we get that if you
want to do polynomial functions let's do
quadratic functions like in tournament
we need to entropies then the entire
intuition generalizes and the idea is
really just that I can rewrite a
quadratic function as a linear function
in the tensor product and I take two
independent snapshots and then average
over all possible pairs of different
snapshots and then I will get something
that is correcting expectation and you
can again compute the variance and kind
of the number of measurements you need
Sacandaga rhythmic in a number of
predictions it's kind of exponential in
the single party party locality of the
quadratic functions you're interested
and there's an additional factor of two
because you're interested in a product
from the polynomial if you're interested
in higher order or any entropies you
won't get an additional multiplicative
factor of two but of
oh hi Richard this is Steve Lamia how
are you hi Mike I have a question about
if we could just return briefly to the D
randomization yes so the this
pessimistic estimators method which is
fantastic by the way
this is a greedy strategy if I
understand it correctly yes and maybe
you said this already and I missed it
do you have matching lower bounds um no
we don't because actually don't I think
I seem to remember that with the
pessimistic estimator you're rigorous
guarantees don't improve can effect the
statement is always like it's kind of
like you start with a probabilistic
method proof for existence like kind of
suppose suppose the probability of
choosing some collection of measurements
such that I predict all of them
correctly is strictly smaller than is
strictly greater than zero then the
method of pessimistic estimators will
find it but is there maybe an
information theoretic argument that you
can make that would say that this kind
of scaling is optimal um we kind of have
information theoretically lower okay now
it's adaptive yes I see where you're
going I actually don't know I just think
that the improvement you can typically
expect it's like kind of constant but
that's a very good good way I believe
you I don't know the answer either
okay so let's thank Richard again